talk about fighting for the soul of
America
but can we level set in terms of the
soul of America right now hate crimes
are on the rise random acts of gun
violence women are under attack Mr
President
the answer is yes because that's why we
can't let well we cannot let this
election be won where the same man who
was president of four years ago becomes
president again
maybe that's right I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it is May 15
2023 and it's been about two weeks
people that's right we did about 10 days
in Israel four days in Budapest then
flew home through turkey had a day trip
here in Florida
then Friday we just took off just to
catch up on a little sleep get the jet
lag in order but we are back in business
I am super psyched to be back in studio
I have to tell you I'm going to tell you
a couple things about the trip and then
we'll get to the normal show but I just
want to start first by saying that you
know that you're doing the right thing
for a living when you actually miss work
while you're away and there were many
days that we were out in Hungary and in
Israel
and traveling on planes buses wherever
we were that I was like man I wish I was
in studio today or I want to talk about
this or that I tried actually not to pay
too much attention to all the racehorse
politics stuff and like the nitty-gritty
of everyday current events and
everything else uh but I missed it I
missed this uh so I am glad to be back
in here with you guys I am proud to say
that no one in my team everyone's in
this room right now two weeks together
pretty much 24 hours a day no major
blowouts unless there's anything I
didn't wasn't
held the breast up no we're all okay
we're good to go uh it really was a
great trip let me let me show you a
couple pictures uh the thing started off
April 27th uh in Jerusalem and I bumped
into this guy you might remember this
guy yeah that's Ron DeSantis the funny
thing is it was really by complete
coincidence our trip which had been
booked like three months ago uh was
supposed to start on April 28th then I
caught wind that the governor was going
to be in Jerusalem giving this talk he
had just come in from South Korea and he
was in Japan before that doing a little
Commerce thing for about a week and uh
we just moved my flight up the team
stayed an extra day back here in the
states we just moved my flight up so I
could go to that so that was great next
up was a day or two later in Jerusalem
this is look at the view on this one uh
so that is that's the Western Wall right
behind us Dome of the Rock behind uh
behind my head there that is Ambassador
David Friedman he was the ambassador to
Israel under Trump who really got the
Abraham Accords done it was he and Jared
Kushner who did that so we sat down for
a really interesting interview I did a
live event in Tel Aviv
bunch of people there that was fun that
was in a former strip club now a place
where a guy like me can hang out uh and
then I did a big talk in Jerusalem at a
free speech conference which was
fantastic then we moved over to uh
Hungary oh no that's oh yeah this is
hungry uh I did an event with the Danube
Institute which was uh really really
enjoyable thoughtful interesting you
know I know far more about Israel and
Israeli politics than I do about Hungary
and Hungarian politics it was really
nice to be in a country that seems to be
doing things right culturally and uh
politically and and see what was going
on there so I enjoyed that and then I
bumped into this guy that's Victor Orban
I posted that picture and everyone said
don't you know he's a fascist and hates
you but he was smiling and seemed very
nice to me so who knows uh then I sat
down also look look at the view on that
one that is spectacular that is blush
Orban no no uh relation to Victor Orban
but he is one of his political uh
deputies and that's right in front of
the parliament which we took a tour of
which was absolutely spectacular in
Budapest and then the whole thing in
sort of a fitting as it started with
DeSantis day one two weeks later uh that
is me and Jordan Peterson he had a show
in Budapest so I opened for him and it
was about 5 000 people uh really awesome
and it was just a nice sort of fitting
ending to the entire thing uh and before
I get into the show what I want to tell
you is that what we did there both in
Israel and Hungary we're shooting or we
shot a a mini documentary might not be
so many it might end up it might have
being end up being legit and oh Phoenix
meet along no no it's long we got a lot
of stuff really trying to figure out uh
what is is right in certain countries
right now and is there something that we
can take back to America you know Israel
for all its problems you know they've
had about a thousand rockets fly into
their territory which ironically did not
happen while we were there basically the
day we left it started for this last
week just a ton of rockets flying in
Iron Dome doing its thing I mean it's
really
remarkable but for all their security
problems and whatever else it might be
there's something culturally there that
really is working it's a people that are
are progressing in the right sense of
progress uh the the building of the
country the roads the cleanliness the
lack of homelessness drugs all that
stuff like something good was there and
it's and it's cultural not just
political and the same thing going on in
Hungary taking care of their borders uh
fighting for their own cultural identity
and all that so that really was what the
the Genesis of the trip was like is
there something going on in these
countries and I hope to do many more
International trips and find the spots
in the world where what is going on and
what is right and why is it working and
can we import some of that into America
because obviously you guys know our our
political institutions our cultural
institutions educational institutions
everything seems to be up in the air and
by the way almost everyone that I talk
to in Israel and in Hungary virtually
everybody was like man what is going on
in America they want to look at America
and be like oh you guys are on the up
and up like the world's kind of good
when you're good but that's not what
people are feeling everyone's kind of
like uh what's the deal with Biden the
Democrats have gone completely insane
there was obviously a lot of talk about
Trump and DeSantis all that kind of
stuff but
all of that being said I think we really
did come up with a nice uh idea set
around the types of things that can be
imported and what brings us together as
Americans and where we can fix things on
the margins and tighten things up so
that we don't have to as I often say be
on this endless descent to hell that we
seem to be on so we'll be uh releasing
the dock possibly
um I'm not allowed to say but soon
enough and I think you will see that it
was a worthwhile trip and just one other
thing on that it was really nice to come
home and and see Justin and Luke who
have grown tremendously while I was gone
but they both gave me big smiles and it
was an acknowledgment that they hadn't
forgotten me so that was very nice too
so today before we do all of the
political stuff that we'll be getting to
for the rest of the week and everything
else I just want to catch up a bit on
some of the things that I missed and and
with some new bites in there as well
because obviously some some major things
happened obviously the the Tucker
Carlson leaving Fox situation this Trump
CNN Town Hall thing and these things are
connected right and I would say it's
actually connected to the culture part
that I'm always talking about which
again was sort of the purpose of this
trip uh what is going on culturally here
that leads us to a place uh where our
media is so partisan where it is so
dishonest and our and our sort of
corporate Elite are seemingly working
against us at all times and of course
that leaves the rest of us the rest of
us with some answers places like Twitter
and Rumble and independent creators who
were fighting against the machine and
maybe there are some political answers
as well because uh I don't know if you
saw it over the weekend but Ron DeSantis
is in Iowa right now Iowa that is the
you know first place that the
Republicans are going to be voting hint
who knows uh but before we get to all of
that let me talk to you guys about moink
box you know that 60 of pork production
comes from one company owned by the
Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called rack depend which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day well there's a better way guys
which is why I want to tell you about
boink which is Moo as you know moo plus
oink Mike delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door you choose the meat delivered in
every box like rib eyes to chicken
breasts to pork chops to salmon fillets
and much more plus you can cancel
anytime there's nothing better than
cooking their meats on my big green egg
on a Friday evening Shark Tank hosts
Kevin O'Leary called moinks bacon the
best bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm just
so happy I got mocked keep American
farming going by signing up today at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get a free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste that is
m-o-i-n-k-box.com
reubenmoinkbox.com Reuben and now back
to me okay so thank you
culturally what is happening here and
what makes a culture well a culture has
a little something to do with the media
right the media is sort of a mirror or
it's supposed to be a mirror of
ourselves unfortunately from an American
context the mainstream media has become
a fun house mirror and it's very hard to
Garner anything true from the mainstream
media these days but the media and our
politics
combined sort of are what everything
else culturally comes from so as you
know last Wednesday night Donald Trump
former president Donald Trump uh did a
town hall on CNN now I've been saying
for quite some time that whether you
like it or not and this isn't even a
condemnation of the guy or an applaud
applauding of the guy that Donald Trump
is part of the machine right he sort of
needs CNN and CNN sort of needs him
right that's why they came together to
do this thing on one hand CNN will lie
about him all day long but they lie
about him and talk about him because it
gets them views he constantly talks
about them because they'll cover him and
he feels that helps him like it's just
it's just how it is that's all it's just
how it is anyway he did a town hall with
Caitlin Collins on CNN on Wednesday
night and then everyone went bananas
because a whole bunch of people in the
audience who were Trump fans were
applauding for Trump so the average
person watching it or the average
Democrat watching it was not happy
because it kind of made Trump look good
so what happened well the next night
Anderson Cooper over there on CNN uh had
to kind of mop up for what CNN had just
done by just playing the game that they
always play
many of you have expressed deep anger
and disappointment many of you are upset
that someone who attempted to destroy
our democracy was invited to sit on a
stage in front of a crowd of Republican
voters to answer questions and
predictably continue to spew lie after
lie after lie and I get it it was
disturbing it was disturbing to see and
hear that person refer to a black law
enforcement officer as a thug an
adjective he used many times to describe
black men and called Caitlyn Collins the
moderator nasty which is what he calls
any woman who stands up to him it was
disturbing to hear him speak so highly
of Q Anon conspirators and
insurrectionists who assaulted police
officers in our democracy on January 6.
and it was awful to hear him spread
ridiculous lies about the election and
it was certainly disturbing to hear that
audience young and old our fellow
citizens people who love their kids and
go to church laugh and applaud his lies
and his continued defamation of a woman
who according to a jury of his peers
he's sexually abused and defamed
as good a job as Galen Collins did
trying to fact check him it is
impossible to fact check fully because
he lies so shamelessly
now many of you think CNN shouldn't have
given him any platform to speak and I
understand the anger about that giving
him the audience the time I get that but
this is what I also get the man you were
so deserved to see and hear from last
night that man is the front runner for
the Republican nomination for president
you have every right to be outraged
today and angry never watched this
network again but do you think staying
in your Silo and only listening to
people you agree with is going to make
that person go away
oh Lord the sanctimony I forgot about it
quite frankly
um first off that that Anderson Cooper
is running around talking about Trump's
lies and everything else like CNN is a
lie Factory they only exist to lie they
just lie in a different direction and
Trump often calls out their lies he's
upset right there and he's having this
sort of Maya culpa because he knows that
the base of the network is turning
against them now CNN is already failing
in the ratings obviously by the way the
reason that so many of us talk about CNN
all the time and show clips of CNN is
because I believe that actually for a
functioning democracy it would be good
if we had some news that was
non-partisan that we could basically
trust we just don't have it but what
he's seeing is that the crazy people the
radicals that they've radicalized right
they've radicalized their own Audience
by constantly lying to them and ginning
it up and making it seem like white
supremacists are everywhere and everyone
who disagrees with them is a big in a
transphobian everything so he's trying
to walk it back a little bit uh I like
the line though you have every right to
be outraged and never watch CNN again I
mean you shouldn't watch CNN you really
shouldn't I know it was on at the
airport when we were there and I have to
see these clips every now and again but
what's interesting really is that this
is that was the night after that was on
Thursday night when he was uh doing his
little recap there and it's like well
all right well so what did happen what
really did happen he listed a couple
things January 6th and okay the election
and so how horrific was the town hall
where well here's one clip that you
might have seen this one went viral I
don't know the full context to it but I
actually didn't want to know the full
context I think it just stands on its
own
her dog or her cat was named vagina the
judge wouldn't allowed to put that in
all of these things he but with her they
could put in anything Access Hollywood
Missouri of nine people who found you
liable of sexual abuse do you think that
that will deter women from voting for
you no I don't think so because I think
the whole thing
just so you understand ready
I never met this woman I never saw this
okay first off that This Woman's cat was
named vagina the way he says vagina it's
just kind of funny uh he did not get uh
hung up on this rape charge by the way
this woman the rape charge failed that
they're getting him uh what was the
charge actually that they're getting
come on that he's gonna have to pay it's
not on rape itself he's not being it's
right it's like defamation it's not that
he's guilty of rape they did not find
that uh but anyway it's like see what
we're talking about you see what we're
talking about this is what they do this
is why they all need each other right
they just need each other that being
said hearing Trump talk about vagina
isn't the greatest thing ever but he did
do something that I've been saying
you've got to do uh consistently when
dealing with the media and that is fact
check them in real time bring receipts
right remember when Ted Cruz was on The
View and they were trying trying to get
him and he busted out some papers and
said I got the facts right here well
Trump must be watching the Reuben report
because he nailed it with this one
when they went to the Capitol and they
were breaking into the capital smashing
Windows injuring police officers why did
you why did it take you three hours to
tell them to go home I don't believe it
did oh let me pull it out
thank you
so
so if you look at
on January 5th the day before I said
please support our Capitol Police at law
enforcement they are truly on the side
of our country stay peaceful stay
peaceful this was the day before and
this was in the form of Twitter now use
truth truth social I think it's far
superior okay I hope everybody's right
I hope everybody's on Truth uh if you
look January 6 at 2 before 2 30
I am asking for everyone at the U.S
Capitol to remain peaceful this is right
after as it was happening but what
happened is they took it down I don't
know why I think they took it down
because it was so good they didn't like
it being up there
okay so there's a couple things going on
here first off the the people are going
all right well Caitlin Collins she did
this great job in the face of trump I
don't really care to make this about her
specifically but she's focusing on rape
charges and the nonsense around January
6th and everything else and Trump uh
actually got quite sick of her uh at
towards the end here check this out
it's very simple that you're a nasty
person I'll tell you
can you answer why I'm very excited I
was negotiating and we were talking to
Nara
so look they deserve each other right
they deserve each other she would never
treat Biden like that Anderson Cooper
would never have to do a follow-up show
on the lies of Joe Biden or the lies of
Karin Jean-Pierre or anything else uh
Trump knows that they're lying she knows
that she doesn't like Trump like it's
all right in front of us right this is a
magic trick and we all know what the
tricks are but they just keep doing this
thing in front of us look Trump won the
thing I watched enough of the clips if
we're looking for a winner here Trump
won cno's CNN knows Trump one which is
why Anderson did that thing after but
CNN also got their best ratings in years
so they asked him dumb
partisan Lefty questions at a republican
town hall with a republican audience
they got their their own at-home
audience to be upset that people were
applauding him he gets more people to
pay attention to more energy around him
and they get the ratings for it so they
get the money for it he gets the
attention so do you see how they are
part of the same machine but the machine
really is spasming right now it really
is right I mean the main thing that
happened while I was gone in terms of
the media was Tucker uh is no longer on
Fox sounds like he's going to be doing a
show on Twitter and the reason I think
it's good no matter what no matter what
happens here is because we are
diversifying where these voices are
coming from right they won't all come
from corporate media they won't all come
from people in their living rooms
they're going to come from a plethora of
places as long as we have the tech to
make sure people can get their voices
out there so we'll get to more of that
in just a second let me talk about
genucel real quick guys you know you can
go to Brazil or Colombia and get work
done to your face but why on Earth would
you do that let me tell you about our
newest sponsor geniusell skin care look
years younger right before your eyes
here's a real review from geniusell.com
Claire said I absolutely love Jen yesel
my skin feels so good Tighter and
younger with a more even tone and I only
used it for a week my advice everyone
take before a picture but her husband
Jim makes a more exciting Point wife
loves it ever since I purchased it for
her things got much more into
interesting after dark enough said it's
true nothing works like geniusell
because it's a family recipe for over 20
years made by a compounding pharmacist
in small batches and always safe cruelty
free and natural now go to genucel.com
promo and save over 70 off janya cell's
most popular package during their
Mother's Day sale every most popular
package features their Ultra retinol and
Dark Spot Corrector don't wait go to
genucel.com promo that's jennycell.com
to get a complimentary spot Essentials
box with every package order plus free
upgrade to priority shipping and now
back to me so why is the media spasming
they don't know what to do they hate
Trump they need Trump trump doesn't know
what to do he hates them he needs them
it's a match made in hell
here's Jake Tapper over at CNN and he's
who doesn't know what to make of all of
this I mean you know he's cashing the
checks so it's kind of good for him but
it's also undermining democracy so I
guess that's not so good here we go
hello from Washington and it was an
interesting night Mr Trump's first lie
was told just seconds into the night
with his false familiar claim that the
2020 election was quote a rigged
election and the falsehoods kept coming
Fast and Furious about the January 6
Insurrection about the threat of Vice
President Pence about Pence's ability to
overturn the election about covet about
the economy and more he called a black
law enforcement officer a thug he said
people here in Washington DC at
Chinatown don't speak English
okay again do you get it why they need
each other then they can sit there and
be outraged over what they just allowed
to happen it's do you think they didn't
know what was going to happen did they
think that Trump was going to get up
there with Kalyn Collins and it was just
going to be a Love Fest and he was just
going to tell the truth as they see it
and everything was just going to go
smoothly of course not but it's exactly
what they wanted and it's not just what
CNN wants it's what MSNBC wants too
because since Trump has left office
msnbc's ratings have absolutely
collapsed and deservedly so here's Joe
Scarborough and look at this actor he's
just an actor
so upset about Trump see it
I I can't believe I'm I'm going to use
catastrophizing language here uh but it
was it was just it was disgraceful on
every level
it showed uh I wouldn't say it's
dangerous for democracy because we
passed that a long time ago
but it showed the corrosive effects of
trumpism over eight years
and I've got to say
I I the most shocking part with an
audience
who cheered on a president who tried to
overturn
American democracy
tried to overturn American democracy
it's true couple hundred people showed
up there on January 6th no weapons no
plans no nothing
one guy they thought he had a Lego set
that looked like the capital turned out
that wasn't even true but this this fake
pompous boring man having stepped away
from this stuff for about two weeks just
watching all of these people it's like
you're all in on the grift together but
speaking of the grift is there anyone
more griftery than the ladies of the
view I think not here's noted racist
Sunny hosting and she used to be on CNN
and she's laying into CNN and her former
friend Anderson Cooper
I think that you don't give a bigot and
a racist and a misogynist and a liar and
cheater and a sexual abuser and a
defamer a platform of three million
people and I'm saddened uh I used to
work for CNN for quite some time
Anderson Cooper has been my friend for
over 20 years and I'm saddened that he
tried to Gaslight me yesterday by saying
that people are in silos people aren't
living in a silo they are choosing to
listen to the lies or not
you're right lady and as one of the
prime purveyors of lies in this country
on that Daily Show every day which is on
ABC right now and thank God you good
people aren't watching it because you're
with me right this moment you spread
this stuff you spread the lies so you
don't mind lies you just want people to
swallow your lives and also keep in mind
there is no Republican that Sunny Hostin
or the rest of these types of people
wouldn't say is a bigot and a racist and
a homophobe and a transform and
everything else right like they think
Trump is the threat right now but as
DeSantis continues to rise and it's very
obviously like that that that's on the
cusp of happening right now
um you're going to see the same as exact
attacks on him actually we've seen them
already and what do I keep saying
they're going to call them Hitler with a
calculator he's going to be Trump but oh
my God he's actually functional this is
going to be a real problem for these
people so they need him he needs them
and they're losing control right they
are losing control not only of the
narrative so the narrative would just be
that Democrats are nice Democrats care
about poor people Democrats aren't
racist and Republicans are mean and care
about war and money and hurting poor
people something like that but we know
that none of this is true so they're
losing the narrative but they're also
losing the distribution models this is
the the key part to all of this it's why
I'm so proud to be at least to the
extent that I am involved in the tech
game to to save some of this stuff so
they realize they need Trump and Trump
needs them one more time they're losing
control of the narrative and
distribution how's that happening well
about 10 days ago out of nowhere the
number one rated Cable News host in the
history of cable television Tucker
Carlson uh was out at Fox found out
about an hour before he was supposed to
be doing his show that day uh here is
Tucker
about a week later Taken several Jabs at
the machine as well as Fox and making an
announcement on where he will show up
next
hey it's Tucker Carlson you often hear
people say the news is full of lies but
most of the time that's not exactly
right much of what you see on television
or read the New York Times is in fact
true in the literal sense it could pass
one of the media's own fact checks
lawyers would be willing to sign off on
it in fact they may have but that
doesn't make it true it's not true at
the most basic level the news you
consume is a lie a lie of the
stealthiest and most Insidious kind
facts have been withheld on purpose
along with proportion and perspective
you are being manipulated the best you
can hope for in the news business at
this point is the freedom to tell the
fullest truth that you can but there are
always limits and you know that if you
bump up against those limits often
enough you will be fired for it that's
not a guess it's guaranteed every person
who works in English language media
understands that amazingly as of tonight
there aren't many platforms left that
allow free speech the last big one
remaining in the world the only one is
Twitter
starting soon we'll be bringing a new
version of the show we've been doing for
the last six and a half years to Twitter
we bring some other things too which
we'll tell you about but for now we're
just grateful to be here free speech is
the main right that you have without it
you have no others
so the importance of this situation
can't be overestimated Tucker and the
amount of influence he has no longer on
Fox News corporate media now look I
basically like Fox I go on Fox several
times a week they never tell me what to
say I say whatever I want to say and
they've been good to me and it is what
it is what it is I would say from my
perspective they obviously from where I
sit made a mistake on this one and I
think this is really going to strengthen
say the the pond that I'm in the
independent Pond right and of course
Tucker is right like you can say a
certain amount of stuff when I do the
show every day it's the way we've always
done it and the way we will continue to
do it we try to do something that's
going to hopefully Enlighten you a
little bit maybe make you laugh a couple
times and and tell you something that is
true and every now and again the guard
rails of that uh can hit back on you
right like so if you talk about uh
vaccine mandates before they want you to
talk about vaccine mandates they could
depress you in the algorithm this is you
YouTube for example or if you said
something about if you misgendered
someone in the old regime of Twitter
they could ban you whatever it is so now
new rails are being developed not only
did Elon Musk take over Twitter with the
intent to make it more open for free
speech not to make it more hateful but
then of course you've got places like
Rumble and locals Etc et cetera uh Elon
Musk actually responded to the tucker
video to describe a little bit more
about what his ideas around speech
online are going to be on this platform
unlike the one-way Street of broadcast
people are able to interact critique and
refute whatever is said and of course
anything misleading will get community
notes I also want to be clear that we
have not signed a deal of any kind
whatsoever Tucker is subject to the same
rules and rewards of all content
creators rewards means subscriptions and
advertising Revenue share coming soon
which is a function of how many people
subscribe in the advertising views
associated with the content I hope that
many others particularly from the left
also choose to be content creators on
this platform so first off just real
quick on the last line there he wants
everybody to be on there right Elon Musk
is going out of his way
to say hey everybody's welcome here and
if you have something worth saying and
want to say it you can have your
audience subscribe you will make some
money on that and you'll make some money
on Advertising by the way guys this is
exactly what we're doing with Rumble and
locals I have a feeling there's going to
be a lot of touch points with Elon but
even if there aren't like I am super
excited that the model that we really
started online for people in this space
is working right it's working and it's
the future the fact that they haven't
even signed a deal with this guy elon's
saying to him it's the same thing I've
been saying about rumbling locals all
along we just build you something we
build you the tools and then you do
whatever you want with it so if Tucker
if Tucker can get 10 million people to
give him five dollars a month and
suddenly he's making 50 million dollars
a month which turns into yada yada yada
per year 600 mil per year whatever it
might be it's not good for him that's
great so there are options here and it's
coming at the expense of corporate media
which whether it's CNN in bed with Trump
while hating Trump or MSNBC lying about
everything or the view whatever or Fox
screwing up by getting rid of the number
one host in cable news history uh it's
good I think for the rest of us that are
forward-facing here and want to find new
business models and new technological
answers to all of these uh problems uh
but I this was absolutely spectacular
this was absolutely spectacular uh Brian
Stelzer remember Brian stelter he was on
reliable sources on CNN the most
ironically named show in television
history uh he now works I guess for
Vanity Fair Vanity Fair is just like a
former magazine it's a former
it's formerly what Vanity Fair once was
it ain't Vanity Fair anymore for those
of you of a certain age but he got a gig
at Harvard and now he writes for Vanity
Fair here he is he went on television to
describe what's going to happen now that
Tucker is free
okay well listen Twitter was already
Under Fire from misinformation
disinformation all out lies
anti-Semitism racism before Elon Musk
took over and now it's gotten kind of
crazy right seemingly unmoored uh if you
will will anybody be able to police what
Carlson says or is this the point it's
just a free-for-all I think this is the
point it is a free fall that's what Elon
Musk wants to provide this move by
Tucker May cement the idea of Twitter as
a right-wing website
guys guys who is going to police Tucker
it is the job of people like stelter to
make sure that what you know and what
information you get is the real
information we can't just have Tucker
out there saying what he thinks
it's so absolutely bananas and of course
what what stelter's really going for
there is see it will cement Twitter as
being a right-wing thing even though all
the lefties are still on there right AOC
is still on there Nancy Pelosi and
Chelsea Handler and every left-wing
lunatic and their brother is still on
there and they have all of the same
subscription tools and advertising tools
as Tucker but the real question is what
do you mean how are we going to let
people just say what they think if they
start saying what what they think they
may not be saying things that we think
and that would be a problem
so guys with Fox CNN Tucker Rumble
Twitter with all of them changing we're
still noticing
trickles of the left-wing machine coming
through right like this this thing it's
somehow you've got what do I always say
you've got to give it credit right like
it's still somehow always leaks itself
in so with all this good stuff happening
with Tucker and Twitter and all of that
um Elon announced this was two days ago
that the new CEO of Twitter is going to
be a woman named Linda yaccarino now she
is a former wef World economic economic
Forum affiliate formerly of NBC she's in
ad sales
um but some video is leaking out of her
and people are going to have to try to
make some sense of this I would just
preface this video by saying I'm willing
to give Elon the benefit of the doubt
here right like
he clearly knew that this is what her
history was they've obviously had some
discussions about it they've already
agreed to do a live Twitter spaces where
people can ask her whatever they want
but it is an alarm it is an alarm and
it's worth noting so here is the new CEO
of Twitter this is her back in 2020
talking social justice and equality
you can talk about you know things that
that my company is doing to
accelerate right to accelerate what we
were doing already but realizing
that it wasn't enough so what
immediately started happening was that
uh under the leadership of Brian Roberts
and Jeff show uh Comcast set up a fund
to the value of a hundred million
dollars to fight social justice and
equality and and obviously supporting
many many important groups but it really
made a very public statement
that we're going to put our money where
our mouth is we're not going anywhere
and it inspired action across every
corner of our company
okay so I'm pinning this just as a as
kind of a note to Elon Musk it's like
all right if you're hiring her as a CEO
here she is talking about how the
company she used to work for threw a
hundred million bucks towards social
justice and the organizations around
that and that seems to be to me to be
counter to all of the things you've been
talking about so he's going to have to
have a reckoning related to that again
he did say he's going to do a Twitter
spaces this is sort of their live audio
back and forth where people will be able
to ask her questions he still remains in
charge of the the product itself so it
sounds like she's going to mostly be
doing the sales side of things but look
when when the walksters get into any
organization we've seen this time and
time again they basically destroy every
organization so Elon I would say is has
a very very tight rope to walk right now
to make sure that this thing doesn't
totally derail we shall see but speaking
of totally derailing I saw this one this
morning this is from Bloomberg Vice
media has filed for bankruptcy
protection punctuating a relatively
rapid decline for the media upstart that
once boasted a 5.7 billion dollar
valuation this is really big guys for
those of you watching this you probably
don't pay that much attention to Vice
but Vice about you know maybe eight
years ago a decade ago like they were
the first sort of alt media right so we
had we had Network News NBC ABC CBS then
we had cable news CNN MSNBC Fox News
then there was like the alt online media
company so there was vice there was
BuzzFeed Etc now BuzzFeed as you know
folded a couple weeks ago now Vice is
worth it's worth nothing it's worth
absolutely nothing after being valued at
5.7 billion because they went woke too
so it proves the theory go woke go broke
that's how it works but the question is
what triggered this Snowball Effect of
distrust and now failure in in the
entire system right our political system
our media system and all of that well
it's in many cases because our political
leaders and our institutional leaders
have just wide relentlessly about
everything and fortunately over the last
couple years as as uh censored as the
internet has been we've had some level
of exposing that nonsense uh here's
video from the DeSantis war room this is
Governor DeSantis talking about the
media and the lies and the rest of it
this is in relation to covid but you
will see the point
you know what our biggest enemy is in
America our fellow Americans frankly we
know that we can't trust the
unvaccinated now is the time to do what
you're told this is not about Freedom or
personal choice no screw your freedom
people who are incubators for every
variant to come walking around lawfully
unvaccinated that's psychotic you've
been patient but our patience is wearing
thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
vaccinated person having a heart attack
yes come right on and we'll take care of
you unvaccinated guy who gobbled horses
goo rest in peace Wheezy you're you're
unvaccinated overcrowd our hospitals
overrunning emergency rooms and
intensive care units leaving no room for
someone with a heart attack or
pancreatitis schmuck this is a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
freedom I want my freedom to live okay
so as I said that was from the DeSantis
war room that wasn't the governor
himself we'll get to him in just a
second but the reason that I wanted to
play that video it shows you this came
from the media like why is it all
crumbling right now why does it feel
like cable news is crumbling the last
vestiges Trump cling on to CNN like that
old world thing it really is collapsing
in real time in front of us and I would
say that the media's continual fall is
that we're seeing right now is
reflective of a broader theme in America
as the machine weakens its counterparts
are strengthening and this is going to
cause the tension the lies of the media
aren't working because there's been
enough good guys telling the truth and
with some ability as I said because of
technology and despite all the
algorithmic tricks to build audiences
and and and disseminate something at
least a little bit closer to the truth
so everyone
everyone is part of the machine to some
extent right we all are I am to some
extent we all are uh but Trump is
definitely part of this machine so let's
uh let's continue uh a little bit to to
this weekend or no let's before we get
to this weekend uh this one happened
right before I left and this one really
uh set me off so you may remember this
truth social post from Trump
uh this is Florida was doing great long
before Ron de Sanctus got there people
are fleeing from New York to Florida and
other places because of high taxes and
out of control crime not because of
Governor thank you president Trump to
sanctimonious Rick Scott did great and
even Charlie Crist had very good numbers
sunshine and ocean very alluring okay so
putting aside writing like a crazy
person in the capitalization and the
disanctimonious which doesn't work and
the fact that all his kids and his
grandchildren all live in Florida and he
lives in Florida and he knows how much
safer it is here and he knows how the
economy is chugging along uh he puts
things out like that because the machine
now knows that the santis is the biggest
threat to the machine right he is a
Conservative Republican governor who
just won by a landslide showed that you
can build a really wide Coalition of
people you can bring in uh obviously the
the conservative side of things but you
can also bring in the disaffected
Liberals and the crossover people the
people who were recently read killed and
woke up during covid and all of that
stuff
so the machine sort of accepts the Trump
lies because then it can get people to
if he says if he's out there saying
crazy things they can get clicks off it
um but I really believe that what people
want right now more than any more than
any time certainly in my lifetime is
people want something true they want
something decent I think they want to
know that it doesn't have to be like
this and guys it does not have to be
like this there was a before time there
was a before covid time there was a
before all of the crazy time and the
algorithms made us nuts and trumped
Arrangement syndrome and the constant
quest for clicks and likes and all of
those things there was a before time and
I think we can get back to it but it's
going to take some competency and
honestly honesty and and real leadership
uh here's a tweet from Becker news
here's one of the good things going on
in that Florida place that apparently
Trump's not so thrilled with Breaking
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis announces
permanent ban on covid mandates and his
outlawing gain of function Research In
the Sunshine State so yeah that's what's
going on right now in Florida it is just
one of the many of the long list of wins
you know obviously Republicans have a
super majority here the legislative
session just closed uh as of Friday so
DeSantis literally every single thing
that he set out to do while running for
his re-election he accomplished right he
did everything he set out to do and more
and I think people are really realizing
it now and I even got this feeling by by
traveling talking to people people are
appreciative of what Trump did they
really are and they should be and I am
for sure but I think people have had it
with the the name calling the
Ridiculousness the cat's name is vagina
and all of the other stuff people want
competency you might find this
interesting Pedro Gonzalez uh tweeted
this this is this is interesting because
yesterday there were events in Iowa
Trump canceled his and DeSantis had huge
huge crowds here's what Pedro wrote
Trump isn't canceling his event in Iowa
because of the weather DeSantis has been
there all day he's still there Trump's
canceling because his attendance would
have been so low compared to DeSantis it
would have humiliated him that's also
why his team is so sensitive today and
what you can see below on the left side
there is Trump his truth social post
where he basically is saying we can't go
to Iowa because of the weather but
nobody was showing up to his event and
DeSantis did two events and they were
jam-packed so there is something
changing on the ground what's what's
interesting to me about that is how will
the machine react to it because for the
80th time today
continue to say it the machine and Trump
need each other so now there's a new
player and they have to figure out how
to operate within that new player but
why is it working why is the new player
Ron DeSantis why is he gaining momentum
it's fairly obvious right like the
policies are good and he doesn't do the
crazy tweets there's there's no personal
nonsense there he's not attacking people
he's just going about the business of
the state which is really all any of us
wanted here was his uh Mother's Day
message yesterday which I thought was
pretty good Madison Mason and Mamie are
lucky to have the best mother in the
world Casey DeSantis thank you for all
you do for our family we love you very
much and there's a picture of the family
that's quite nice I thought we would
juxtapose that with what Donald Trump
put up yesterday on Mother's Day happy
Mother's Day to all in particular the
mothers Wives and Lovers of the radical
left fascists marxists and Communists
who are doing everything within their
power to destroy and obliterate our once
great country please make these complete
lunatics and maniac Kinder gentler
softer and most importantly smarter so
that we can quickly make America great
again look guys and I know some of the
Trump people are not happy with me and
will continue not to be happy with me
but we can either choose the latter we
can choose that emotion and the cat's
name is vagina and the radical leftist
blah blah blah or we can try something a
little bit different that we all know is
probably a little bit better
right and I think it's fairly obvious
which way I think we should go the
question is which way you think and and
the rest of the country
um but let's hear from DeSantis himself
on uh what it would take to win and and
how you can do it without uh all the
over-the-top stuff
so don't buy this idea that we can't
expand our our basis support of course
you can do that you can't win big with
just Republicans and we've proved that
but here's the thing we didn't do it by
trimming our sales we didn't contort
ourselves to be anything that that we're
not we LED boldly we LED conservatively
and we delivered results and people
responded so that is a lesson from Iowa
with what governor Reynolds has done in
Florida with what we've been able to do
and at the end of the day governing is
not about entertaining governing is not
about building a brand or or talking on
social media and virtue signaling it's
ultimately about winning and about
producing results and that's what you've
done in Iowa and that's what we've done
in Florida
yeah and that's just true Iowa is
flourishing right now Iowa Kim Reynolds
who I had on the show about a month ago
she's the governor of Iowa you know
she's
importing many of the good ideas of
Florida that blueprint that we're always
talking about that's what she's doing in
Florida right now when it comes to
education and policing and covid
policies and much more so that was
DeSantis yesterday in Iowa so it's like
intense something seems to be happening
here but DeSantis continued to talk
about sort of what you would have to do
actually to win the next election I
guess in case he was to run
both Florida and Iowa show
strong leadership and a bold agenda can
defeat the left in this country but
there's no substitute for victory we
must reject the culture of losing that
has infected our party in recent years
the time for excuses is over we got to
demonstrate the courage to lead and the
strength to win if we do that if we make
2024 election a referendum on Joe Biden
and his failures and if we provide a
positive alternative for the future of
this country Republicans will win across
the board if we do not do that if we get
distracted if we focus the election on
the past or on other side issues then I
think the Democrats are going to beat us
again and I think it will be very
difficult to recover from that defeat
yeah if the Democrats win again it's
like man what what would be left what
would be a future of America that would
have anything to do with freedom or
Liberty or competency or any of those
things I don't know so we really have to
make a decision right now and I got to
tell you guys as we as we wrap up here I
I didn't know exactly how I wanted to do
the show today Phoenix and I discussed
it a little bit over the weekend and
then this morning because I sort of was
thinking man do I want to get right back
into all the political stuff do I want
to get right back into DeSantis and
Trump and everything else so the reason
that we sort of recapped a little bit of
what happened last week and it leaves us
with what happened yesterday in Iowa uh
is definitely connected to this trip
that I just took these two countries
that I went to uh that have have massive
challenges particularly Israel border
Rockets all of this stuff the people
there still want freedom and they still
want to fight for their identity and
culture and all of those things and
that's what's happening in Hungary too
they wanted they did they wanted to stop
the migration because it's ruining so
many parts of Western Europe and you
know now the Brussels and everybody else
is always angry at hungry because
they're protecting their borders they're
protecting their culture I think what we
have to do in America is what is our
culture we have had it pretty damn great
for 250 years we have had this culture
of freedom and liberty and get off our
back and let us let us live freely as we
wish but we have to we have to enrich
that and we have to double down on that
and we have to show the people who
engage in identity politics that it is
it is absolutely toxic in a system where
we have people from all over the world
who have come here to make a better life
and they have consistently done it they
have used our freedoms against ourselves
but we're gonna have to start getting
serious that's why I think the message
of DeSantis beyond the good policies
right you get the good policies and even
if you don't get the good policies you
can just look where do people move
they're moving here they're not leaving
here so right you get that but it's more
just like hey how about we just go about
the people's business then you'll figure
out the rest of the stuff you have to
deal with in your life and we don't have
to talk about cats named vagina and we
don't have to talk about nasty women and
rape charges and everything else we can
go ahead and like I don't know live a
good decent life that's my plan here I
think we got some work to do to make it
happen uh but I'm glad you're on the
journey with me guys it's me Monday over
at the Reuben report locals Community I
did my first ever video meme it's a
video game
foreign
[Music]
is there anything worse than the paper
straw I hate the paper straw I can't
deal with the paper straw every time you
go to California it's the paper straw
hate those people guys if you haven't
subscribed join us on rumble.com
reubenreport if you want to play along
during the show with live commentary and
for the post game show which will be up
in about a minute go to Ruben
report.locals.com we leave you this with
this fun edit of Anderson Cooper and Joe
Biden we are back baby we'll be doing
regular news and everything else I
wasn't that funny today
all right I owe you one guys it should
have been funnier on my comeback show
you never wrote be funny it was not in
my notes today I will be funnier
tomorrow but it is good to be back post
game show reubenaport.locals.com see
everybody else tomorrow
good evening before we begin with
tonight's broadcast I want to say
something about what we witnessed the
last night's Town Hall many of you have
expressed deep anger and disappointment
it was disturbing
that man president of the United States
predictably continued to spew lie after
lie after lie you're okay you're not
gonna you're not gonna get coveted if
you have these vaccinations it is
impossible to fact check fully because
he lies so shamelessly it's one thing
that the vaccine which we didn't have
when we came into office and it was
certainly disturbing the Hispanic and
the African-American Community
particularly in uh rural areas that are
distant and or inner city districts know
how to use know how to get online you
have every right to be outraged today
and angry never watch this network
[Music]
thank you